In this video, we'll look at how to use Burp Suite to enumerate usernames.
You can use Burp Intruder to insert a list of possible usernames into an authentication mechanism,
such as a login form or registration form.
This enables you to identify valid usernames that can be used in other attacks.
Using a list of enumerated usernames greatly reduces the time and effort required
to force a login in a password guessing attack.
It can also be used for attacks on user data or sessions.
To try this out, you can follow along using the lab Username Enumeration via Subtly Different Responses
in our Web Security Academy.
If you're following along using the lab, make sure you use the list of usernames included in the lab instructions.
Once you've launched the lab, access the lab using Burps Embedded Browser
and try to log in with random credentials to create a login failure message.
Go to Proxy, HTTP history and identify the failure message.
In the message, highlight the username value, right click and select Send to Intruder.
When we now go to the Intruder Payloads tab, because we highlighted it when sending the request,
we can see that the username has been automatically selected as a payload position.
Now go to the Payloads tab, choose Simple List and set up the list of usernames you want to test.
In Burpsuite Professional, there is a pre-configured list of usernames under Add From List.
In Burpsuite Community, you will need to create your own list.
As we're testing using the Web Security Academy Lab, we're going to paste in the list of candidate usernames
associated with the lab instructions.
Next, go to the Settings tab.
Under GRET Match, we can select Flag Result Items with Responses Matching These Expressions,
where we can use a default list or add our own.
We can also set up our own GREP Extract to search for sections of interest in the response.
Under GREP Extract, select Add.
Highlight the section in the response that you want to extract, such as an error message.
Click to add the item to the list.
Now, when we click on Start Attack, this section of the response will be extracted for each request.
Once the attack is finished, study the responses for any behaviour that may indicate a valid username.
This could be a difference in error messages, different response times or status codes.
In this example, we can see one error message is missing a full stop.
To investigate the contents of a response in detail, we can right-click and select Send to Comparer Response,
and also do the same for the original response.
Now, when we go to the Comparer tab, we can select the two responses and click Word or Bytes to highlight any differences.
We can select the two responses and click Word or by the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link.
Thank you.